[Music]
hello everyone Perry back with another
Stumptown interview I am so excited to
have the rest of the cast on the couch
right now to kick off here all three of
you have resumes that are just down to
the floor at this point so can you
isolate one specific quality about your
character that you've never gotten to
play before
suelen blackbird I have I don't think
I've ever had the opportunity to play
someone who was power broker and highly
educated and right at the top of not
only her game but every game that's
coming around I'm looking forward to
that I like the sound of that and as for
toki a I just know he has some very dark
secrets and I tell you but it's it's a
dark secret you know I play a lot of
lawyers and people in uniform and
doctors and generally I'm there as a
part to move the story along and in the
procedural and it's it's very rare when
my character gets to have a real life
who is flawed and has a soul and has
some serious issues in her home life and
I think we're gonna get to meet all of
these characters as they really are not
just in their uniforms or in their in
their work life but who they are at home
and I'm really looking forward to that
this is so random but given what you
just said is there any profession you've
yet to do that you really want to play
oh gosh there's so many options out
there you know I I don't know I mean I'm
I'm interested in artificial
intelligence I'm interested in
technology there you know I wouldn't you
know mind being the brainchild of some
new technology that is good for the
planet I feel like someone needs to call
up the folks behind Black Mirror and
make this happen ASAP and now cold for
you you're pretty new to the industry
right now so what is it like jumping
into a show like this and specifically
getting to work so much with people like
Kobe and Jake are you nervous at all I
was nervous
for sure but after I get to talk to them
a little bit I get to enjoy the story
what they're saying and I get to them
like you didn't know I met my favorite
part of Athena some meeting new people I
like that I like meeting new people to
Adrian curious with you and Colby just
your back and forth because I was
talking to her and Jake about their
comedic sensibilities that I know you've
got some comedy chops of your own so
what was it like working on that back
and forth between the two of you I gotta
be honest I hadn't been familiar with
Kobe's work until we were on set working
together and I felt an instant kind of
like brotherly connection with her you
know like and you don't see it in the
show that's sort of like guardian angel
looking out for her because she's really
pushing herself out there that says the
character and I feel like I gotta look
out for her as the kind of like brother
brotherly way and but I instantly felt
connected to her because she's the real
deal
she's very genuine their hearts in the
right place and have complete faith in
this in this show because I I'm a big
fan as well
although I feel like all of our viewers
just gasped have you not watched any of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe movies
I'll get to it okay so on Collider we
play a movie and TV version of the game
would you rather often so it's picking
between
two options and then briefly telling me
why you would choose one or the other so
anyone can jump in here would you rather
play a character you can easily relate
to or someone who is entirely different
from you
entirely different well it's like food
you know like I don't want to eat a
burger every night you know like I just
want to mix it up you know you're
talking to a creature of habit every
opportunity is welcomed
so either way either way it's roll it's
a lot easier to play roles that you're
used to you know you put me in a suit
and I cross my arms and I'm a badass and
that just comes really naturally to me
but it's a lot more exciting to play
something that you've never done before
you know that you have to research it
you have to start meeting you have to
you know it's I think that's why we love
it you know to keep it exciting keep the
flame a fire
got to play new and interesting
characters and to answer your other
question I'd like to play the President
of the United States how about that I
think we can make both options like that
why not
how about for you call me and Michael we
have the same thing because I played
soccer in real life and ends up playing
soccer and some town all right here's
another one for you guys would you
rather run for an entire scene or eat
throughout an entire scene is that an
actual question because that seems like
it just would be you'd rather eat for an
entire scene like who would want to run
the eating over and over and over for so
many takes it stresses me out though the
running over and over for somebody takes
totally stresses would rather eat on a
treadmill and that way I'm burning off
well a you know you're cheating at my
game but I'm okay with this oh we run
see these people all right here's a
different one here's a comic-con themed
one for you guys oh boy I can thank koi
for this one would you rather have
telepathy you couldn't turn off or every
time you sneeze you turn into beasts
from x-men you are such a nerd I'm okay
with that where they're comic-con I'm
celebrating it oh my god let's go on the
beasts reserved beast is super cool yeah
I don't know who beast is but I think I
should pick that because on my comic-con
and that makes sense I mean I have to
let methey and I knew you were gonna ask
me that all right one last question to
wrap this up so we have the pleasure
right now of speaking to the four of you
we got to talk to three other cast
members before but there are so many
people involved in making a TV show so
if you can name one unsung hero thus far
in Stumptown someone who maybe brighten
your day when you were having a tough
time who would it be
the way in Johnson I like the sound of
that he brightens a lot of days he does
I can just look at his Instagram and I
walk away with a smile on my face
happy Lake every time he works out I
won't work out I have that same feeling
you know last night I was hanging out
with one of the the producers of the
show he's a young kid named Eli and he
is the one who found Stumptown and
brought it to the producer so kind of
without Eli we didn't have a show
he brought Greg Rucka who is the writer
and Cheston who was the illustrator he
brought the show the graphic novel to
the producers attention to ABC's
attention so I think Eli's a little bit
of an unsung hero definitely a good
person to shout out yeah yeah I think
the whole creative team is is really
exciting and and gives me a great sense
of confidence that we're gonna come up
with something very entertaining and
sharp and a personal shout out to Greg
Rutger who wrote the books who I had an
opportunity to have several drinks with
him one night and this guy really knows
his stuff and gave me some insights on
how he could see Tukey going in a
particular direction as well as the
other characters and he's the real deal
great I'm so excited to see the show
guys ABC September 25th a huge thank you
for your time I hope you guys have a
blast while you're here at Comic Con to
everybody out there thank you for
watching this video don't forget to like
and share it and stay tuned because that
end card is gonna have another Stumptown
conversation you could click on guys
keep an eye on the channel we'll be back
with more comic con coverage soon